sac à main portefeuille ou encore porte
carte en avril 2020 les à Beaune lance
LB maroquinerie l'artisienne de 24 ans
crée de la maroquinerie haut de gamme et
colorée aussi bien pour les femmes que
pour les hommes donc du coup là je suis
sur une commande pour Noël d'un petit
sac Camille en fait c'est une
[Musique]
sacoche qui se met aussi bien à la
ceinture que en banane donc là c'est
pour un modèle Homme et là je suis en
train de faire en fait les finitions
donc j'arrive sur la fin du sac donc
c'est les finitions de tranche de la
bandoulière en fait de la sangle où je
viens appliquer en fait une teinture
pour avoir des bords qui soient plus
esthétiques entre chaque couche de
peinture je viens poncer pour lisser
remettre une couche et en général je
fais deux à trois couches
et entre chaque couche je laisse sécher
attirer depuis son enfance par les
activités manuelles et créatives c'est
après le bac qu'elle décide de se former
se spécialisant auprès des maisons de
luxe dans le savoir-faire français
patience et qualité sont les maîtres
mots pour travailler le cuir la
créatrice s'approvisionne donc auprès de
tannerie françaises et italienne en
règle générale je montre 15 et 20 heures
pour faire un sac pour chaque création
tout commence avec une idée ou une
commande et quelques coups de crayon sur
un carnet ça en fait c'est les dessins
de base en fait quand je réfléchis et
donc après je fais tout le côté après
technique donc je réfléchis à toutes les
parties qui va me falloir travailler les
dimensions
du coup donc le produit fini donc avec
la sangle qui est fixée donc qui est
ajustable
mettre en avant les métiers de
l'artisanat et le savoir-faire français
est important pour la jeune femme mois
durant mes études quand j'étais enfin
collège lycée
on nous parlait pas du tout de ces
métiers là je les ai découverts bien
après et c'est vrai que ça manque parce
que
il y a des personnes qui sont faites
pour ça donc c'est dommage de passer à
côté en fait compter entre 20 et 400
euros pour vous offrir un de ces modèles
de quoi vous donner peut-être des idées
à mettre au pied du sapin